is there another way to fight the
russian military if you don't dress in
uniform if you don't own a gun hello
this is marie fdevo from har ki of
ukraine
thank you
it was maria of deva for you
21st of march harkee of ukraine
maria adjieva is a lawyer and an
academic from the embattled city of
harkeef and she's gone to war with
vladimir putin
her strategic objective is simple she's
determined to document the truth
and russia continues
bombardments and challenge
the residential areas harkie city center
everywhere
you have watched
this city change dramatically
over the last three weeks
yes it's it's
very hard to see and
hard to see but critical to witness says
ms fdeva who has deployed her smartphone
and her legal training to record the
destruction in her hometown
someone has
to to be active in this information
battlefield to show the truth what is
actually happening because this
information battlefield is the same
important as the on the ground military
operations so i'm inside the building
which was heated by a russian rocket
this night
ajieva doesn't want the ordeal to be
overlooked or forgotten or denied by the
russian government's media machine
russian officials accused the ukrainians
of bombing their own buildings
in our world we have all kinds of
sources and we know what is
disinformation what is propaganda and
their people live constantly in this 24
7
russian tv world where they are fed all
these kinds of
lies
the truth in
is frequently tragic
here the owners of a city center art
gallery try to fit their favorite
paintings into a soviet-era car
the rest were left behind
this bombed-out residential complex
served the staff at a nearby technical
institute
the russians accused them of developing
biological weapons but they shelled
three apartments instead
mr java said she had to document the
scene we asked for for any kind of help
from from west but uh on the ground here
in in our cities it will be only us and
if you know we will all live who will
fight for ukraine
so you stay yeah that's why i stay
thank you this was maria deva for you
from kharkiv ukraine with john sparks
sky news in harkev okay